vu les restrictions mises en place en
espagne face à la hausse des cas de
mikron la population semble aborder
cette période avec un certain calme
grâce à la protection vaccinale
c'est ce que nous explique philippe
emmanueli il est médecin français exerce
à barcelone
la population a réagi avec beaucoup de
sérénité par rapport à la flambée de ces
quarts notamment parce que le message
qui passe essentiellement c'est que les
populations à risque ont été vaccinées
on observe bien effectivement dans les
maisons de retraite par exemple qui
était vraiment le point sensible la
première vague retour des contaminations
sa maison contre elle mais par contre on
n'observe pas effectivement l'importance
des cas graves qui avait pu être
observés et donc pour la population
c'est un petit peu comme si l'essentiel
avait été assurée par la protection
vaccinale et simon sont les
contaminations cas l'on devait insister
maintenant étaient des contaminations
peu symptomatiques peu grave est qu
effectivement eh bien on pouvait passer
au travail